AH ! Tu regrettes ?
AH ! Ça ne sert à rien de chialer ! AH ! Vermine !
AH ! Sur ton visage !
(Ah elle sont cool tes baskets !)
Je t'ai pas autorisé à parler fils de p*te ?!
Pfffff.....
Excusez-moi j'étais en train de péter la gueule à un de ces mecs qui arnaquent les gens sur Instagram
Vous les avez vus, ils sont très nombreux , ils sont partout
Je parle bien evidemment des fakes, des gens qui usurpent notre identité à nous,
grands youtubeurs célèbres, comment osent-ils ?
Fin de carrière pour Squeezie
Ils profitent de l'innocence des plus jeunes d'entre nous, vous rendez-vous compte ?
Alors, sur YouTube, excellent site qui permet à deux personnes d'avoir exactement le même pseudo ÇA BALANCE !
L'arnaque se fait sous forme de "clique sur ma photo"
Alors, pourquoi ils veulent tant que vous cliquiez sur la photo, je vais vous le dire
Youtube permet aux youtubeurs de taper des mots qui seront bannis
C'est à dire si tu postes un commentaire qui contient ce mot, ton commentaire ne passera pas
il dégage, immédiatement à la sortie ça rentre chez soi
On aurait dit une phrase d'un enculé de raciste mais non, BREF PUTAIN, on fait une vidéo sur le racisme
ou sur les arnaques là?! En tapant la commande *links* dans les mots bannis
ça bannit automatiquement tous les commentaires qui comportent des liens
Donc là les arnaqueurs ils étaient : .....
*Cri de la PLS*
En PLS !  Ils se sont donc dit : "Au pire on leur demande
de cliquer sur notre photo
En se faisant passer pour le youtubeur en question
Et en arrivant sur notre chaine y'aura une vidéo absolument
dégueulasse en anglais qui les incitera à se faire arnaquer, bref toujours la même chose
Ils vous promettent un truc de malade, il faut cliquer sur un lien, machin
Tu te fais arnaquer, bref. Morale de l'histoire ne cliquez JAMAIS  sur la photo
de profil d'un youtubeur, ça va plus vite, ça dégage vraiment toutes les arnaques
On en parle plus. Bref nous aussi on a été jeune
Et nous aussi on sera vieux et dans les deux cas la technologie nous dépasse un peu.
On est pas habitués
On n'a pas eu beaucoup d'expériences avec donc on peut facilement se faire avoir.
Moi même ça m'est arrivé quand j'était petit mais je vais vous en parler après pendant qu'on attendra quelque chose.
Deuxième type d'arnaque sur Instagram quand vous suivez un Youtubeur connu
français qui est très beau et dont les vidéos sont absolument extraordinaires.
Je parle bien sûr de Euh... De Squeezie.
Il y a automatiquement des bots qui vont vous follow.
Mais c'est presque immédiat enfin j'espère sinon cette vidéo est nulle à chier.
Ces gens se font passer pour nous et vont essayer de vous contacter
Et vous faire croire qu'on vous fait gagner...Un iPhone pas un Samsung.
Un iPhone. Les amis ce qui va se passer aujourd'hui
ça va être hyper sérieux. Pas comme ces lunettes
Hé Daredevil il aurait pas dû mettre ses lunettes il imposerait carrément plus le respect mon gars
On va infiltrer le réseau d'arnaqueurs et le détruire par l'interieur
Attention...ETAPE 1 Créer
un faux compte Instagram. Bienvenue sur Instagram Je me suis
créé un compte qui s'appelle baptistelebgdu78 Parce que
quand un mec s'appelle Baptiste et qui vient du 78 il est beau gosse
Tout d'abord on va ajouter une photo qui va faire croire que je suis très très fan...de MINECRAFT !
Comme ça il va vraiment croire que je suis une cible facile extrêmement jeune. Voila c'est très bien ça
ETAPE 2 Follow des Youtubeurs Français
*Musique Stylée*
ETAPE 3 Attendre qu'un petit FD*
morde à l'hameçon
OH ! Ça mord putai*
*Bruit de canne à pêche*
Squeezie me suit...MEC wow c'est vraiment lui
C'est sa photo officielle et tout. Et Norman aussi ! Ils se sont passés le mot !
Ok donc vous l'aurez compris se sont des gens qui se font passer
pour nous sur Instagram. Et qui font des faux concours
d'iPhone 7 voila mais pour participer au concours il faut que t'appelle
un numéro payant et que tu lui donnes le code qu'on t'aura donné au téléphone.
Quand t'auras payé 3€. Voila. Mais attend je suis con on est mal infiltrés
J'ai posté aucune photo sur le compte et j'ai même pas mis de description.
Je suis passé sur tablette car on ne peut pas voir les messages et conversations sur "Instagram computer" version.
Je poste une photo de moi-même ça n'a aucun sens ce qui se passe.
On va faire genre que je suis très très très fan comme ça le mec va vraiment très s'enflammer
pour que je tombe dans son piège du faux concours. Ça va être très drôle
Voilààà...
Oh regardez ce qu'il y a dans ma TL put*** Natoo elle fait gagner tellement d'iPhone
J'offre des iPhone 7S au premier qui aime et commente
*Respiration stressée*
"Moi"
"Je vous aime mes fans, bonne chance à tous !"
Mais tu as pas honte enculé !?
P*tain mais quel bâtard !
Alors en attendant qu'il me contacte par Message privé, je voulais vous raconter une anecdote
Qui m'est arrivée quand j'étais petit...
J'ai failli me faire avoir par un spam de : "Cette technique marche à tout les coups. Gagnez à la roulette grâce à la technique de David Lapurgasse
J'étais descendu en courant chez moi pour aller prendre la carte bleue de ma mère pour lui dire
(Voix de petit enfant innocent) Maman on va être riche j'ai trouvé une technique de fou !
"Ferme ta gueule Lucas"
Mais maman je te jure ça marche j'ai fait le test et ça marche !
Oui parce que l'arnaque était bien faite, il te permettait de jouer un coup gratuitement et la technique marchait; parce que c'était truqué !
Mais quand tu mettais des vraies thunes ça marchait plus !
Oh ! "_Natooogram" maintenant, "Coucou"
"Tu veux participer pour gagner L'iPhone s7 gratuitement comme les autres fans"
Espèce de mytho va ! Il y a que moi qui ai commenté ta photo ! Sale mythomane !
*écrit* Oh oui j'aimerais bien !
Je marque en gras et tout c'est absolument ignoble mec !
J'ai envie de voir à quel point ils prennent des gens pour des cons
C'est ça le but de cette vidéo !
*écrit* Mais comment je peux savoir que c'est vraiment...
'Tain il corrige trop Android. Arrête de corriger ce que j'écrit c'est chiant
D'accord tu dois me suivre étape par étape pour que tu puisses recevoir ton iPhone après 48 heures de ta participation
D'accord, en tout cas pas après que tu aies appris à bien parler français sal...
On est infiltré, on doit pas s'énerver
Tu es intéressé par quelle couleur ?
Noir. Prouve-moi que tu es bien Natoo
C'est mon deuxième compte je l'ai créé pour la compétition des fans et c'est moi personnellement qui a choisi les participants
Ça n'a aucun sens ! (rires)
Je vais parler avec le micro. Ça marche ça ?
"Et pourquoi tu ne le fais pas sur ton compte principal ?"
Je suis trop con d'un coup je parle parfaitement bien français c'est génial ! (rires)
C'est bien maintenant pour confirmer ta participation le système te demande 10 codes reçus gratuitement par téléphone.
10 codes... Il doit pas il y avoir beaucoup de gens qui tombent dans le piège pour qu'ils demandes autant de codes mec...
Un code c'est genre 2 ou 3 euros, vous vous rendez compte ?! C'est abusé
Mais c'est encore plus des fils de p*te que je ce que je pensais !
P*tain
Oh ça fait du bien !
Tu réponds quoi à "Et pourquoi tu ne le fais pas sur ton compte principal ?"
T'abandonnes ? Espèce de lâche !
Salut tu veux quoi comme offre le iPhone 6S ou l'iPhone 7S ou le Galaxy S7 ou Galaxy S8 ?
Le s8 steuplé
Et je vais lui demander si c'est vraiment Squeezie quand même... C'est bizarre.
OOh, Natoo qui nous répond
Parce qu'il y a beaucoup de fans qui a participé
C'est pas le but d'un concours ? Qu'il y ait le plus de fans qui participent ?
"Voilà appelle ce numéro" Oh regardez ! Il donne vite le numéro en mode : Pose pas trop de question vas-y je vais t'étouffer
Appelle 3 fois il y a un mec qui va te donner le code d'accès tu me le passes corect
"Le prix qui vont te dire à chaque appel 3 euros c'est juste pour la publicité des Marseillais + Service illimité t'inquiète c'est gratuit l'appel ok ?"
Quoi ?!
Mais mec c'est génial !
Mais moi le truc de la roulette quand je me suis fait avoir c'était au moins  bien foutu !
Là c'est juste de la grosse merde !
Le prix qu'ils vont te dire à chaque appel 3 euros c'est juste pour la publicité des marseillais
*rire*
Je suis con ou pas ?
Plus service illimité.
Ça a encore moins de sens avec cette phrase, je suis désolé.
Du coup c'est la publicité des marseillais qui payent les 3 euros à ma place en fait d'après lui.
Franchement un gros bisous à tous les marseillais vous êtes archi sympas (rires)
Je vais peut-être gagner un iPhone grâce vous c'est tellement cool !
Attends je vais la mener en bateau...
"Prouve moi que c'est toi envoie-moi une photo"
Et je te fais 30 codes j'ai vraiment envie de gagner l'iPhone
Il va devenir fou !
"Oui avec plaisir ! Mais on doit d'abord terminer la participation" (rires)
Mais mec ! Je vais pas participer avant de savoir que c'est vraiment toi p*tain !
"Mais je vais pas participer avant de savoir que c'est vraiment toi !
Envoie-moi une photo s'il te plait !"
Mec d'un coup j'écris parfaitement français, il va croire que c'est la police il va paniquer (rires)
Je sais pas où ils sont ces gens là...
Mais non arrête de dire ce que je dit Google, arrête je vais me faire griller !
Merde, MERDE !
AHAH !!!
L'infiltration a raté !
"oups, trompé de conversation désolé !"
"Squeezie Hauchard, élu pire employé du FBI durant 4 années consécutives"
Oh il m'a envoyé une vidéo, c'est quoi ça ?
"J'ai reçu l'iPhone 7, ce n'est pas du fake, appelez bien les numéros, écoutez bien les codes, donnez bien toutes les informations, allez sur concours_gagner_iphone7. Au revoir.
Mais mec... Mais c'est horrible...
Mais mec c'est affreux comme ils manipulent des enfants quoi !
Mais mec alors là... alors là !
Et arrête de pleurer là ! (racaille)
Oh p*tain !
"Mais ça ne me prouve pas que c'est toi, je veux une photo de toi avec marqué iPhone 7 sur une feuille que tu tiens entre tes mains."
Est-ce que cet homme est vraiment fort ? Et va réussir à Photoshoper... Je veux voir jusqu'où ils vont en fait.
P*tain mec... L'enfant c'est glauque là... Olala...
Oh ! Cyprien !
"Coucou je te choisis parmis mes fans pour un cadeau, choisis la couleur que tu veux iPhone 7"
Noir.
Oh il est en train de me répondre
Alors, "quel pays ?"
Oh le batard ! Il veut gagner en crédibilité en faisant genre "Quel pays ? Quelle adresse ? Ah peut-être c'est compliqué Ah..."
Attends je vais lui donner un pays hyper paumé !
Vatican ! (rires)
Si je lui dis Vatican, est-ce qu'il grille que je suis un fake ou alors il se dit "Ok pas de soucis c'est un enfant du Vatican"
Vatican (rires)
Mec si il grille pas il est génial !
Alors je suis désolé de vous dire qu'on a perdu Natoo. Qui a vu mon message mais qui ne m'a pas répondu.
Natoo je suis vraiment très déçu...
Cyprien a vu Vatican, il ne m'a pas répondu (rires)
Attends je vais tenter une blague
"J'rigole France oui"
Le mec a vu Vatican il a vraiment appelé son manager : "Oh p*tain il y a un mec qui est au Vatican qu'est ce que qu'on fait ? C'est peut-être la police qui est en train d'infiltrer le réseau !"
"Abandonne, abandonne !"
"Tu dois terminer maintenant sinon le système va te bloquer !"
Mais mec c'est des enc*lés ils mettent une pression de ouf quoi aux gens !
"Nooon steuplé"
Attends on va lui envoyer une vidéo
Non mais steuplé je veux juste savoir que c'est toi et je te fais les codes je veux trop l'iPhone steuplé
Ok la vidéo est envoyée (rires)
Il doit se dire "P*tain j'ai le bon boloss du jour !"
Oh p*tain il est en train d'écrire...
Qu'est ce qu'il va répondre à ça ?!
Est-ce que ma vidéo l'a touchée en plein cœur, il va abandonner son projet d'arnaquer un enfant sans défenses...
"C'est moi mon capteur marche pas fait moi confiance si tu termines les codes tu vas rien payer"
Pourquoi d'un coup il écrit bien français ?
Il pense que ça va me convaincre ?
"Mais tu as publié une story insta il y a 2 minutes"
J'le rend ouf (rires)
Vous savez pourquoi je suis content ? Parce que son temps à un gros c*nnard de m*rde qui a aucune race !
"Au clavier..." haha mais c'est quoi ct'expression ?
Il est au clavier, ça arrive, attends il est au clavier...
"Oui mais avec un autre téléphone" Ben connecte-toi sur l'autre téléphone "lol"
Popopooo !
Alors quelle va être la prochaine excuse ? Je pense qu'elle va être aussi crédible que moi quand j'ai oublié de faire mes devoirs en 5ème.
"Pas maintenant je suis en compétition apr..." (rires)
Il me fatigue ! P*tain !
Pour faire ça ils prennet les mecs qui ont la pire impro de tout les temps quoi c'est incroyable !
"Compétition de quoi ?"
"Gymnastique ? lol"
(rires)
Bah je me mets à son niveau mec !
C'est clairement des gens qui sont dans d'autres pays quoi !
"Au revoir"
(Rire/Tristesse)
Ils aiment tellement pas les blagues !
Entre Vatican et gymnastique ils en peuvent plus quoi !
Tu lui dit qu'il y a un gymnaste au Vatican c'est bon il se suicide le mec
Les amis c'est la fin de cette infiltration au sein d'un réseau d'arnaqueur et surtout de gens très très bornés !
N'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si elle vous a plu, j'ai essayé d'en parler en s'amusant
Ne tombez pas dans le piège de gens qui veulent vous arnaquer en se faisant passer pour des Youtubeurs !
En plus la plupart des Youtubeurs sont maintenant certifiés sur les réseaux et puis quand bien même ils ne le seraient pas, ils ne vous feront jamais gagner des trucs...
Ta g*eule Squeezie, ta g*eule
On vous fera jamais gagner des trucs en échange de codes, c'est impossible !
Que ce soit sur Instagram, sur Youtube, Twitter, bref n'importe où sur internet ne cliquez pas sur des liens bizarres sur des espèces de concours ça n'existe pas, personne ne fait ça
Je suis désolé pour tout ceux qui sont tombés dans le piège de ces gros FD* au moins ça sert de leçon, ça vous arrivera plus ! Faut voir le positif c'est vrai.
Moi si ma mère aurait dit oui ce jour là, BIM elle perdait 50 balles !
Bref le message est passé, je vais chercher mon chèque auprès du FBI, et je vous dis à bientôt !
Ils t'ont tous grillé boloss t'auras pas de chèque !
Okay, nouvelle vidéo, bonjour, je me suis fait virer du FBI.
[OUTRO]